pat yeah can i ask you a question
because i think the line of questioning
that you're asking dr peterson is
overall
you're talking about being the reluctant
hero
that was the sort of the initial analogy
that you gave you gave with joe rogan
where like the guy said you know that's
not what joe is joe is not trying to be
a hero and you're like sometimes
you know it's not
who you want to be it's who people need
you to be i mean it's like the joe isn't
trying to be here no he's just being
here no no okay
yeah but but you know it's almost like
neo from the matrix he's like it's like
we need you you're the chosen one what
are you talking about so pat
essentially what he's asking it was like
lincoln
you know churchill
uh trump even these are people whether
they were reluctant heroes or not these
were people that had chan have changed
the world and you're more saying like
look
sigmund freud
gandhi uh you know more the
philosophical line but ultimately what i
think pat is getting at is like who
changes the world more
dignitaries presidents prime ministers
or thinkers thinkers and you say it's
thinkers so that's all for sure it's
thing okay so that is ultimately and
that's even why you guys are happening
right now both churchill and lincoln
i mean they're a melding of the two
leaders
yeah yeah yeah so that's ultimately what
your line of questions all i'm saying is
listen all i'm saying is the following
i'm sitting there looking at a lot of
guys that should there should throw
their name in the and go out there and
compete and they're not yeah and that's
a problem yeah okay so
well look a lot of the people i know
who would make excuse me who would make
extraordinarily competent political
leaders so these are people who've
built
exceptionally complicated enterprises
from the bottom up in an extremely
creative and diligent way and who
mastered that they won't throw their hat
in the political ring partly because
they have other things they're doing
that are they regard as more significant
and often they are and this is a big
problem because what it means is that
perhaps is that the pool of qualified
political candidates is much narrower
than it might otherwise be
so and that's something you're obviously
wrestling with ethically you know when
are you when you called upon to throw
your hat in the ring in some sense
despite your own personal interests
i don't have any
contempt for
the political arena you know i think
it's a big mistake for people people go
from naive to cynical
and then they think cynicism is wisdom
and it is compared to naivety
but it's not compared to what comes
after cynicism which is something like
courageous trust and that's the right
attitude towards
to have towards the political sphere and
often people don't want to take the risk
of courageous trust and so they justify
that avoidance with their cynicism i'm
not like that i know the political realm
is valuable and necessary
and and i don't have contempt for it and
i don't think anyone should
it's it's a mistake because it's your
system man and you're a sovereign you're
an it's sovereign individual it's your
system if it's corrupt that's on you i
can have in a
definite sense and people say well there
isn't anything i can do as one person
it's like joe rogan's one person
and he didn't he his success is really
remarkable
first of all you can't just
push it aside as
chance because rogan was a good fighter
and that's hard
and then he was a good comedian
and that's really hard
maybe no harder than being a fighter but
hard and then he had a pretty good tv
career and that's hard too i forgot he
was on news radio which was yeah yeah i
mean
rogan's rogan's establishment yes
exactly
established
his credibility in three different
domains and then it's also extremely
difficult to be a good interviewer you
actually have to listen yeah and he
listens
and so
and so rogan's rogan's a very good
example of someone who
as an individual
stayed closely allied with the truth and
has had well his we have no idea what
his impact is going to be because rogan
has 11 million
listeners per episode now
i see absolutely no reason why he won't
have 20 million listeners per episode in
a year especially if people keep trying
to take him out and it's so funny
especially watching cnn go after them
you know they're all treating the
mainstream media they keep treating joe
like he's the fringe i think are you
people well i know your
these legacy news media
sources are dying all their really
competent people have already gone off
to do other things because they could
and and they're they're they're living
in like 1975
which is a very weird place to live at
the moment and they look at rogan and
they think
but the cn cnn guy who was criticizing
the other day said we have all these
departments devoted to
news analysis
i believe yeah yeah rogan is just
winging it's like you try winging it
buddy in front of 11 million people and
see how successful you would think
that's easy dancing on a tightrope
where any word you say that's false is
going to result in well complete and
utter pillaring of you from multiple
news media sources all over the world
every day which is what's happened to
joe nonstop in the last month despite
the fact that he hasn't said anything
stupid so wing it you think that's so
easy it's not so easy and look what he's
done it's like admits amazing so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]